we too often let the external the
material thing serve as indicators that
we're doing well even though something
inside us tells us that we're not doing
our best and we're avoiding that which
is hard but also necessary that that
we're shrinking from rather than rising
to the challenges of the age and the
thing is in this new hyper competitive
age none of us none of us can afford to
be complacent that's true whatever
profession you choose professors might
earn the distinction of tenure but that
doesn't guarantee that they'll keep
putting in the long hours and late
nights and have the passion and the
drive to be great educators the same
principle is true in your personal life
being a parent is not just a matter of
paying the bills doing the bare minimum
it's not just bringing a child in the
world that matters but the acts of love
and sacrifice it takes to raise and
educate that child and give them
opportunity the one thing that I feel
deeply about and this is something like
I'll feel deeply about what I leave
government is stuff gets better if we
work at it
and we stay focused on where we're going
it doesn't immediately get solved and I
warned against this when I was running
for office because everybody have the
hope posters this is going to be an
ongoing project and it's a project of
citizens it's not just fix it it's how
do we work together to things done and
it will be imperfect the VA is better
now than when I came into office
government works better than when I came
into office the economy by every metric
is better than when I came into office
and so the reason I can sleep at night
is I've sold myself you know
it's better now am I satisfied with it
no and should voters be satisfied with
it absolutely not because otherwise you
know if we get complacent lazy then
stuff doesn't happen you just watched
two amazing clips from Barack Obama take
the next three minutes to sit quietly
and think about how you can apply them
to your business and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]